Welcome back to your Danish citizenship exam companion.
This is Chapter Five, Episode Two: literature, from the Modern Breakthrough to the middle of the 1900s.
At the end of the 1800s, Danish writers decided to shake things up.
The so-called "Modern Breakthrough", det moderne gennembrud, at the end of the 1800s wanted to break with National Romanticism and society's traditions.
The authors tried to challenge the attitudes of the day to, for example, religion, culture, family life and gender roles, which until then had been taken for granted.
Among the most important new works of the time is Herman Bang's Ved Vejen, "By the Roadside", from 1886.
Herman Bang lived from 1857 to 1912.
The works describe experiences concerning gender and society that the age preferred to forget and avoid talking about.
Another main work from this period is Henrik Pontoppidan's Lykke-Per, "Lucky Per", from 1898 to 1904.
Pontoppidan lived from 1857 to 1943.
His great novel is about Per, who has grown up in the countryside in a priest's family with traditional values.
He goes to Copenhagen and experiences the modern society's possibilities with, among other things, industry and science, but also a new rootless existence.
Per has big dreams and plans for a modernisation of Denmark.
Pontoppidan received the Nobel Prize in Literature in 1917.
Martin Andersen Nexø, who lived from 1869 to 1954, wrote especially books about poor people and their fight for better working conditions and living conditions.
Particularly well known are the novels Pelle Erobreren, "Pelle the Conqueror", from 1906 to 10, and Ditte Menneskebarn, "Ditte, Child of Man", from 1917 to 21.
Both novels have later been made into films.
The author Emma Gad, who lived from 1852 to 1921, wrote a number of plays about the questions of the day such as gender roles, morals and politics, which were performed at the Royal Theatre and other Copenhagen stages.
Emma Gad also thought that people, through clear rules, should be helped to be together without conflict.
She is therefore first and foremost known for "Takt og Tone – Hvordan Vi Omgås", "Tact and Tone: How We Get Along", from 1918, which is the best-known Danish book about how one should behave.
The book contains a number of very concrete pieces of advice about what to do in almost every imaginable situation in everyday life.
For example, you must not put your elbows on the table or put the knife in your mouth when eating, men should lift their hats when they greet, and children must not interrupt adults, but only answer kindly and politely when spoken to.
In the Danish literary history of the 1900s, Johannes V.
Jensen, who lived from 1873 to 1950, and Karen Blixen, who lived from 1885 to 1962, are some of the most appreciated authors.
Johannes V.
Jensen's best-known novel is Kongens Fald, "The Fall of the King", from 1901, a historical novel about sixteenth-century Denmark.
It tells about King Christian the Second's futile fight to keep power as king.
Christian the Second reigned from 1513 to 23.
It is about brutality, ambitions and the beginning of Denmark's gradual decline to a small state towards the 1800s.
Another main work by Johannes V.
Jensen is Himmerlandshistorier, "Himmerland Stories", from 1898 to 1910, which is a collection of shorter stories about peasants and poor people in Himmerland in Jutland, where Johannes V.
Jensen grew up.
In 1944 Johannes V.
Jensen was awarded the Nobel Prize in Literature.
Karen Blixen's best-known work is Den Afrikanske Farm, "Out of Africa", from 1937.
It is about her experiences in Kenya in the first decades of the 1900s, which at that time was a British colony.
Blixen tells here about life on her coffee farm.
She is on the one hand marked by the European colonial masters' way of thinking, but on the other hand she is critical of the colonial masters and their treatment of the African population, and she tries to arrange life on her farm in a different way.
Her work expresses her love for and respect for Africa's peoples, culture and nature.
She also tells the tragic love story she herself experiences with an English man.
Karen Blixen published, in both Danish and English, a series of stories about human passions, longings and dramas of life, which have made her known all over the world.
Tove Ditlevsen, who lived from 1917 to 76, grew up in a poor working-class family in Vesterbro in Copenhagen, and she dreamed already as a child of becoming a poet, even though her father said that girls could not become that.
She wrote poems, novels and short stories about being a child, a woman and poor in the society of the time, and among her main works is Barndommens Gade, "Street of Childhood", from 1943.
Tove Ditlevsen has in recent years, long after her death, also become popular abroad, especially in the USA, Great Britain and Germany, where her memoir series, Barndom, Ungdom og Gift, "Childhood, Youth and Dependency" in the English editions, from 1967 to 71, has been published in new translations.
Among the authors of the 20th century, Klaus Rifbjerg, who lived from 1931 to 2015, was one of the most productive.
Best known is the novel Den kroniske uskyld, "The Chronic Innocence", from 1958, which tells about the youth of society and school life.
The novel's blunt and funny criticism of school and the narrow-mindedness of adults has made it popular with generations of young readers.
In Danish: Karen Blixen was a forfatter, and the Nobel Prize in Literature is Nobelprisen i litteratur.
Here is your recap for Episode Two.
The Modern Breakthrough at the end of the 1800s broke with National Romanticism.
Herman Bang wrote Ved Vejen in 1886.
Henrik Pontoppidan wrote Lykke-Per, 1898 to 1904, and received the Nobel Prize in Literature in 1917.
Martin Andersen Nexø wrote Pelle Erobreren and Ditte Menneskebarn.
Emma Gad wrote Takt og Tone in 1918, the best-known Danish book on manners.
Johannes V.
Jensen wrote Kongens Fald in 1901 and received the Nobel Prize in Literature in 1944.
Karen Blixen wrote Den Afrikanske Farm in 1937, about Kenya.
Tove Ditlevsen wrote Barndommens Gade in 1943.
Klaus Rifbjerg wrote Den kroniske uskyld in 1958.
Now it is time for your exam practice.
These are real questions from past Danish citizenship exams on what you just heard.
For each one, I will read the question and the choices, then pause so you can pick your answer, and then I will give you the correct answer.
Question 1.
Which Danish author received the Nobel Prize in Literature in 1944?
Option A: Klaus Rifbjerg.
Option B: Steen Steensen Blicher.
Option C: Johannes V.
Jensen.
[DA] Hvilken dansk forfatter fik i 1944 Nobelprisen i litteratur?  A: Klaus Rifbjerg  |  B: Steen Steensen Blicher  |  C: Johannes V. Jensen
The answer is C: Johannes V.
Jensen.
It appeared in the June 2020 exam.
[DA] ✔ C: Johannes V. Jensen
Question 2.
Which Nobel Prize did Johannes V.
Jensen receive in 1944?
Option A: The Nobel Prize in Physics.
Option B: The Nobel Prize in Economics.
Option C: The Nobel Prize in Literature.
[DA] Hvilken nobelpris fik Johannes V. Jensen i 1944?  A: Nobelprisen i fysik  |  B: Nobelprisen i økonomi  |  C: Nobelprisen i litteratur
The answer is C: The Nobel Prize in Literature.
It appeared in the November 2023 exam.
[DA] ✔ C: Nobelprisen i litteratur
Question 3.
Who wrote the novel Lykke-Per around the year 1900?
Option A: Carl Nielsen.
Option B: Christen Købke.
Option C: Henrik Pontoppidan.
[DA] Hvem skrev omkring år 1900 romanen Lykke-Per?  A: Carl Nielsen  |  B: Christen Købke  |  C: Henrik Pontoppidan
The answer is C: Henrik Pontoppidan.
It appeared in the June 2020 and May 2023 exams.
[DA] ✔ C: Henrik Pontoppidan
Question 4.
Who wrote the novel Den kroniske uskyld in the 1950s?
Option A: Ludvig Holberg.
Option B: Klaus Rifbjerg.
Option C: Peter Høeg.
[DA] Hvem skrev i 1950’erne romanen Den kroniske uskyld?  A: Ludvig Holberg  |  B: Klaus Rifbjerg  |  C: Peter Høeg
The answer is B: Klaus Rifbjerg.
It appeared in the November 2020 exam.
[DA] ✔ B: Klaus Rifbjerg
Question 5.
What is Karen Blixen known for?
Option A: She was a ballet dancer.
Option B: She was an actress.
Option C: She was an author.
[DA] Hvad er Karen Blixen kendt for?  A: Hun var balletdanser  |  B: Hun var skuespiller  |  C: Hun var forfatter
The answer is C: She was an author.
It appeared in the November 2020 exam.
[DA] ✔ C: Hun var forfatter
Question 6.
Who wrote the novel Barndommens Gade from 1943?
Option A: Naja Marie Aidt.
Option B: Leonora Christina Skov.
Option C: Tove Ditlevsen.
[DA] Hvem har skrevet romanen ”Barndommens Gade” fra 1943?  A: Naja Marie Aidt  |  B: Leonora Christina Skov  |  C: Tove Ditlevsen
The answer is C: Tove Ditlevsen.
It appeared in the November 2021 and May 2025 exams.
[DA] ✔ C: Tove Ditlevsen
Question 7.
Which Danish author wrote the book Den Afrikanske Farm?
Option A: Karen Blixen.
Option B: H.C.
Andersen.
Option C: Tove Ditlevsen.
[DA] Hvilken dansk forfatter har skrevet bogen Den Afrikanske Farm?  A: Karen Blixen  |  B: H.C. Andersen  |  C: Tove Ditlevsen
The answer is A: Karen Blixen.
It appeared in the June 2022 and November 2024 exams.
[DA] ✔ A: Karen Blixen
Question 8.
Who wrote the novels Pelle Erobreren and Ditte Menneskebarn at the beginning of the 1900s?
Option A: Steen Steensen Blicher.
Option B: Martin Andersen Nexø.
Option C: Klaus Rifbjerg.
[DA] Hvem skrev romanerne Pelle Erobreren og Ditte Menneskebarn i begyndelsen af 1900-tallet?  A: Steen Steensen Blicher  |  B: Martin Andersen Nexø  |  C: Klaus Rifbjerg
The answer is B: Martin Andersen Nexø.
It appeared in the November 2022 exam.
[DA] ✔ B: Martin Andersen Nexø
Question 9.
Who is known for having described how to behave in Takt og Tone, Hvordan Vi Omgås, from 1918?
Option A: Herman Bang.
Option B: Emma Gad.
Option C: Karen Blixen.
[DA] Hvem er kendt for at have beskrevet, hvordan man skal opføre sig i ’Takt og Tone – Hvordan Vi Omgås’ fra 1918?  A: Herman Bang  |  B: Emma Gad  |  C: Karen Blixen
The answer is B: Emma Gad.
It appeared in the November 2023 exam.
[DA] ✔ B: Emma Gad
That's the end of this part.
Well done.